- (applause)
- I love when you come on my show!
You haven't been here in a minute.
- I know!
- Last time you were here,
you were super pregnant.
- [Jenna] I was so pregnant!
- [Kelly] Yeah!
- I mean out to here pregnant.
- Is he three now?
- Three, going to be three, in March.
- Yeah, going to be three, that's right.
- Yes, about to turn three!
- That's exciting.
- It is, he's so cute.
Oh, my Goodness.
- [Kelly] Oh my God, time flies, though.
- [Jenna] Right!
- Especially I feel like people
were here and COVID happened
and then everybody came back with babies.
- Yeah, we all had Covid
babies, incubating.
- Yeah, Covid babies.
- There's only one thing to do,
and I guess everybody did it well.
(laughing)
You're welcome mom!
Do you do anything special,
to start the year like it's a new year?
- I have a thing, I don't
love resolutions, I used to
- [Kelly] Me neither, I fail at them.
- Me too.
- I set them too high.
- I think I do the same
and then I feel bad 3-4
weeks in when you're like
oh, I'm back to doing.
- Yeah I don't feel bad
about it but I do fail at it.
- See I did, and then
I realized I was like,
well why am I doing this, you know?
So I tend to do a word, which is easier
and it's a little bit more
of an intention, right.
So it's not so
- You pick one word?
- One word.
- Okay, what's your word?
- So this year is embody.
Which for me, a lot of people
are very confused by this word.
- I'm not! I like the word embody.
- It's like the physical
element of it, of course.
You know, actually like being healthier,
but then the living and breathing,
your talk and you know,
walking, you're talking.
- Embodying what your words.
- Yeah, embodying your words
and embodying how you would like to live.
- That's hard, I think you did
set a really hard goal there.
Depending on what you're saying, I guess
- You're like come December,
I have embodied nothing.
(laughing)
- But maybe that's nice,
being still, we never do that.
- Well, that's the thing is
like the little decisions I make
throughout the day, you know,
trying to make the small choices better
so that you overall feel better.
- Yeah.
- But I have found when
I started doing that
you would get to the end of
the year and you would see
how that was sort of, like an
intention for your whole year.
- It's in your subconscious, I believe.
Yeah, when you set some
kind of intention like that
and it's boring if you
don't set any kind of goal
or intention, that's boring.
- Yeah, and I'm super woo-woo in this way.
- Me too.
- You too?
- Yes.
- Have we never talked about this?
- So, well, I've watched
your show, you did a show.
Is it Witches of East...
- Witches, you went, yes!
- Love.
- Witches, yes yes!
- I love it.
So you're into all things
like kind of mystical, right?
- Yes.
- Have you been like that
since you were a kid?
- Always, but no one in
my family really was.
- Me neither.
- You either?
- Yeah, and I like totally
believe in magic, like yeah.
- For sure.
- Because I've experienced it,
I've experienced feeling
like magic, that's nice.
- And it is wild when you
put something out there
and you actually take steps
to achieving something,
when it happens, you
definitely feel magical.
- Yeah, and I believe that
people that don't believe in it,
aren't open to it.
- That's true.
- It's on you.
- It's kind of like what you
believe you create, you know.
So I'm with that.
- Yeah, Oh yeah.
- Witches was funny
because I did that role,
but I was already Freya, in so many ways.
- That's what I was gonna say,
did that attract you to that role?
Because you already
like that kind of stuff?
- Yes I saw that and I was
like oh this is gonna be fun.
- Yeah, I know your projects, girl.
So I wanna show a photo that
you posted 'cause this is me.
This is all of us.
This is rare though, for a mom I feel like
to get a minute without your,
- [Jenna] Yeah.
- I literally with the last bath,
this is no joke, the last bath I took.
My kids got in the bathroom still,
and I locked it, I thought, still got in
and I literally this is no joke!
I taped something and sent it to my band.
Not me in the bath!
I just mean like that would
have been inappropriate, HR.
No, I taped it and I was like,
they won't leave me alone.
And I was just filming my kids,
not leaving me alone in the bath.
How did you get alone time?
- For sure, this is
really rare for me too.
The balancing act as a mom, I mean,
it is honest to God, the
hardest thing, we all know this.
But I have to, like, set a time,
and if I don't set a time
to do it, I don't do it.
- Schedule it yeah.
- So it's like I'm scheduling, you know,
at 8:00 PM this is happening.
I don't know what meltdowns going on.
I don't know what's going
on, but I'm doing it.
And so obviously,
if a glass of wine is
involved, even better.
- Or just relaxing in the bath is so good.
We do so much all the time.
- And I don't, I talk about it a lot.
But if I don't actually schedule it,
I don't do time for myself.
- Or force it because, like,
sometimes because even
the last bath I took,
I was like or I could just lay in bed.
- [Jenna] Yes!
- And then and then I was
like, your body needs it.
Like, the Epsom and I got like lavender.
I get into a bath girl, I
have like a whole set up.
- Same.
- Yeah, I'm like rose oil.
- Same!
- Candles.
- And they're like put
a cup of Epsom salt,
I'm like, dump the whole pack.
- Oh my God are you only
supposed to put a cup?
It depends on the size
of your bathtub, I guess.
You know the chemistry of it
but I put a lot, like half the bag.
- Same I was like we need to cleanse.
Like we're going half the bag.
- It's like lavender, I've like
doped myself into a stupor.
Like I'm just totally tired.
- And I slept really great
because I put the whole bag in
my bath, yeah I do the same.
- I love that for you
every mom was like, yes.
And dad, maybe you like
baths too, I don't know.
- Yes.
- So your son's, you said
about to be three, right?
So do you do like big parties and stuff?
I get into it.
- Yeah, we do.
You know, I started off being like,
we're not gonna do big birthday parties,
you know, less is more
and his second birthday we
had a big basketball theme.
It turned into a whole thing.
But this year he started preschool
so we actually have friends.
And he's normally just
around Evie's friends,
you know, so he's like, I have friends.
So we're going to try and do a party.
He's so into garbage trucks,
I know that's hilarious.
- Oh, my son loves trucks, he's six, yeah.
- Do you drive around
and see garbage trucks
even if he's not in the car
and be like, oh, garbage truck!
- It's like the game
slug bug, I feel like.
You know, like when we were
kids, it's like you always
if you're playing, you
see them everywhere.
- Same, he's obsessed, so I'm thinking
- My son loves fire trucks,
so he would love your
character in The Rookie.
- Callum also loves fire trucks.
- [ Kelly] Yes, loves the fire truck.
- He doesn't know that I
play a firefighter yet.
So that's gonna be really awesome.
- That's gonna be really cool.
(applause)
- So our daughters are about
the same age, so is it true
that she's like completely taken
over your Spotify playlist?
- [Jenna] For sure.
- [Kelly] Oh my gosh,
beautiful little thing.
- She's so cute.
Yes my Spotify has been taken over.
However, Evie is into Irish dance.
So this is her biggest, hugest passion.
- [Kelly] This is interesting.
Where did this influence come from?
- We watched Riverdance, I swear to you.
I showed her Riverdance
videos and she was like
she looked at me, and all honesty
and was like I want to do
this, find me a dance class
and we had done ballet,
tap wasn't looking good.
It was not, she wasn't into it.
I googled, found a woman here
and she started classes
and she became obsessed.
We are at dance competitions,
we do the whole thing.
- Are you the dance mom?
Smile, baby!
Like are you?
- No, you know what's funny
is I grew up as a dancer, obviously.
- Yeah, obviously, yeah.
- Dance competitions, but
my mom was not a dance mom
and so she was really grounded.
So I'm at these competitions,
but there are moments where,
and Evie is really good, she
does great, she's amazing.
But there's moments where I'm like,
I wanna tell her to point her foot,
but I can't because then, you know,
you're the mom telling her what to do.
So I'm kind of well I
can get around to it.
And she's like, I don't wanna hear it,
I don't wanna have it.
In the back of my mind, I'm
going I do this for a living.
Like there are some critiques
that I can give you.
- Yeah I'm actually a good
resource at this moment.
- I'm a good resource,
like I can tell you if you
- [Kelly] She doesn't care.
- Nope.
- My daughter performed
singing in a school thing
and yeah, she didn't want any input.
And I was like sure, don't ask me.
- But I get it.
(laughing)
Don't ask me.
- I was fine about it but
I was just like, all right
but you know what we're raising
like confident, bold
women and I love that.
- I was actually, I'm great
with it I think it's adorable
and I want her to have her own experience,
I don't wanna give it to
her but it is really funny,
it's like here I am back
at dance competitions.
But that's why my Spotify, she
only listens to Celtic music.
So my Spotify is like the Celtic Woman,
who by the way is amazing.
I love them but it's also Irish
jig music and the heavy jig.
- That kind of is happy music.
- It's super happy, but
you know 15, 20 minutes in
you're like, could we Top 40?
Anything?
- Any other genre will do.
- We are Celtic woman, Celtic
Christmas, we've got it.
- I love that it's cool to see your kid
watch something though
and get inspired by it
and it's important I think for them
to find something they feel confident in.
That's outside of friendships,
outside of school,
outside of you know what I'm saying?
I don't know, I feel like that's where
when you started dancing,
was that kind of your outlet?
That what singing was for me.
- For sure.
It's the biggest boost
for your self esteem
to have anything that
you're passionate about,
that you're also feeling
good while you perform
or feeling good while
you're creating something
and she found this, and it lights her up.
You're also getting
positive reinforcement,
and you have something that,
I really love that it's physical
and something that teaches you discipline
and we're there two, three times a week
and she's learning Oh, I might
not get something right away
but then if I keep working
at it, watch what happens.
It's wonderful.
I couldn't, I'm so happy about it
and I'm a full Irish dance mom.
- You're a dancer, have you
ever done Irish dancing?
- No!
- That's like the one
thing you've never done.
- The one, the one I've been clogging.
- She picked something she was like,
she's done all this I'm
conquering over here.
- She I think honestly
in Evie's mind there was
a part of her that was like,
this is the one thing my mom
- Yeah. I'm gonna be.
- No one has done this,
she's a total free bird.
Like a very unique little girl.
- [Kelly] That's awesome!
- Yeah.
- What an amazing woman she's gonna be.
- Now I wanna take lessons, though.
I said this looks really fun.
- But then you're gonna be that mom.
We can do this together.
- It's true, you're right.
No, we can't do that.
- Because I do this too.
I'm like maybe I'll start doing that,
then I'm like, oh, wait.
- No, she's like can I
have anything for myself?
- Yeah, but you do like sharing things
with them so that that's hard sometimes.
- I know!